Vô quan vũ chủ gắng ấy là Trung Quốc CMSI Chubiet
tổ vũ chủ thần châu,
hâm hiệp bà đã gép nổi thành công với cha vũ chủ thân công
vào giận sáng ai hàng lập thành năm
vài giờ sau khi được phòng từ Trung tâm phòng vậy
tình từ tuyên bằng tên lửa trường trình hà e
theo CMSI tổ thần châu,
hâm hiệp bà đã thực hiện quy chính tiếp cất và gép nổi nhân hoàn toàn từ đâu
vời mô đuôn lỗi thiên 2 trong khoảng 3 phy năm tiến
và phy hành ra sau đó sẽ vào mô đuôn này
nơi phy hành ra hoàn thần châu,
hâm hiệp mô đăng chở bản rao yên bô
phy hành raoàn thần châu,
hâm hiệp bà,
gồm chú,
dàng chú,
dàng dàng gì và lý dàng dinh
người không cóm đầu tiên thăm ra chương trình không giàn
tổ người lại của Trung Quốc
một chân yên vũ quan trọng của thần châu,
hâm hiệp bà đã đưa một phy hành rao liều lại
vì đạo xuất mũ t năm trọng
để nguyên kiểu tá động của mùi trường
vi trong lực trọng thời gian dài.
Bắc kìm cho biết đây là bước trình vi
cho kế hoa đường người đô bộ mặt trang
trường nằm hành hiệp bà mùi
đông thời phy hủ vụ
các sự mạnh khẩm ra sau trong tình like
bao gồm cả sau qua.